Daniel Jeremiah are on the Rich Eisen
show give me the scuttlebutt DJ buddy
got for me why there's a lot of buzz
building rich I think the confidence
level um with you is it's around the
league there's some skepticism I'm not
gonna lie to you but I think there's a
core group of us that I think you've got
what what it takes to get it done do you
think so yeah I think it's in you I
think you've got that memory are they
saying what are they saying I mean give
me give me the scouting report I really
I I can take it this is my fee I think
thirteen 14th time doing this I can take
it I've heard it all well you know look
I have it hasn't been confirmed there
are some rumors that you're involved in
a dog show and it's or did you have too
many interests
it's like Josh Rosen it's what you're
saying like never insane Rosen is too
many interests it's more than just about
football for Rosen that's what they're
saying about Isaac now yeah dog show I
don't know that but there's a lot of
rumors about somebody else doing one all
right DJ
I'll be I'm comedy you don't I'm gonna
use enemies fuel for my fire fuel for my
fire I'm trying to get I'm trying to get
Mayock to where the Jason Kelsey yeah 20
times so okay
going into the combine what do you think
the main story is give me that give me
that one I mean well I mean look it's
sometimes it's artificial and this time
it's authentic its tits the quarterbacks
I mean I can't remember a year we had
this many that were talented name-brand
you know name program guys we've known
the average Joe has known about all
these guys for a long time and it's not
just the big five I mean we talk about
the big five with with Rose and Arnold
Mayfield Alan Lamar Jackson but then
even guys in that next here like Mason
Rudolph and Luke Falk have been you know
putting up numbers and been name brand
college players for a long time so
there's a lot of guys gonna get a chance
to watch go out there and spin it you
know and then on your move the sticks
podcast with Bucky Brooks you had Mike
Vick on this week talking about Lamar
Jackson and he said that
that Lamar Jackson reminds him of him
from a scouting point of view would you
agree with that assessment well look
Mike came in two years before I started
scouting so I was I was around like a
lot and I'm I was with the Eagles when
he came there and spent time there I
would say Mike was a little bit more
natural as a passer just a little bit
cleaner mechanically but I mean arm
strength wise and and just raw athletic
ability I definitely think there are
some similarities there okay and in
terms of his viability of being a
first-round quarterback going in what do
you think DJ I think he's got a good
shot I've been on record as saying I
think he's a top 40 pick you know I
don't think he gets out of the early
portion of the second round because
second rounds usually where you'll see
guys say okay me there's a little bit of
risk involved here he's not a finished
product by any stretch but the talent is
just too overwhelming yeah and you're
not going to get you're not going to get
blown out of town from missing on a
second-round pick like you wouldn't a
first-round pick I still think there's a
legit chance he goes in the bottom of
the first round but I'd be shocked if he
didn't go early second well I mean it's
a copycat league here and if we just saw
Nick Foles
win a Super Bowl with rpoS being a
central facet of the offense without him
having much of a threat of the are of
the PIO I mean why not why not Lamar
Jackson DJ yeah that's why that's what
I've said it you look if this was the
Dan Fouts era you know ok people be
dismissive and how's this gonna work but
it's not I mean look at how the game has
changed look at how Houston more if
their offense around to Shawn Watson the
success he was having is is the example
people point to we had a chance we're
gonna have a podcast coming out
I think it's early next month where we
go and kind of focus on just one player
and we interview a bunch of people we
talk to Lamar Jackson's high school
coach who changed his offense that he
had run he's been coaching for 40 years
changed his offense for Lamar Jackson
was successful and we talked to the
coaches at Louisville who had Petrino
had his offense he transfer ever he gets
Lamar Jackson he changes it and morphs
it around his skill set so that's what
the NFL team is going to have to do and
it's proven to be successful but you're
not going to be able to just call the
existing plays you've always
you have to incorporate it and build
around them which is what any good coach
should do at any level now while we're
on the subject of quarterbacks here
obviously the way that the draft shakes
out will be affected by the way that
free-agency
shakes out which teams do you think are
gonna take themselves off the draft
board for at that position based on what
it's gonna happen new league year hits
in March DJ well I think you're gonna
see a lot of these teams double up try
and double up with the free agent and
then also go ahead and just pick a guy
so you don't have to rush him onto the
field I would say the one exception
being whoever gets Kirk Cousins I think
that number and with his age I think
you're committing to him so I've been
going with Minnesota is the best fit for
him I think that the you know your jets
or the other team that's mentioned but I
think Minnesota's probably where he ends
up but I think a team like like if if
Cleveland signs AJ McCarron does that
take them out of taking a quarterback at
1 or 4 I don't think so
if if Denver ends up getting Case Keenum
does that you know keep them from maybe
taking a guy like Josh Allen who could
sit for a couple years behind a guy like
Keenum I mean I think you're gonna see a
lot of guys doubling up a lot of these
teams doubling up interesting and what
do you think of the Blake bortles
signing look it makes sense from the
standpoint of what options are out there
you know I know that we haven't reached
a quote-unquote legal tampering
period but I would think they'd have to
have an idea of what the market for
Cousins was going to be that was the one
guy that was out there that I would say
that was the obvious upgrade for them
but you know if that number is too high
and out of reach and you already
committed to Blake a little bit for this
year I think when you look at the
options available to you this made sense
and I think really about restructuring
than the number to make it more likely
they could keep Alan Robinson that's
that's what makes a lot of sense okay so
the poll question is read it - read it -
Daniel Chris Brocklin go for it yeah did
you what do you think of the Blake
bortles contract extension great man lol
probably maybe with not as much fat as
you pronounce it well I mean but so let
me let me pound the table in the manner
in which I did in our number one would
you may have missed because I know
you've got sick kids at home and you're
getting ready to go to the combine
Daniel so let me pound the table here
for blackboard was okay that he there
was one batted down pass away from him
making the Super Bowl that he that he's
a maker of stars Daniel he's a maker of
stars look at that look at the cast that
he damn near almost took to the Super
Bowl saying Blake bortles is the
greatest showman he's a he's the he's
the Hugh Jackman of NFL quarterback yes
I'm saying that also he is he's a he's a
tarp remover it's working it's working
they're taking the tarp off there I mean
why would you go away if you can just
keep on keepin on with him and see if he
is the right guy you can't sit here and
say and I say this to a talent evaluator
you can't sit here and say he over the
next two years can't become one of the
tops in a league right I don't think
you'll be one of the tops in the league
but I think he's been in a situation
that's probably more desirable than any
other situation in the league when you
look at some different factors here when
you let's look at a the offensive line
and running game they have in place
which they've done a really good job of
building up that's that's a good spot to
be in you look at the most talented
defense in the NFL I don't think anybody
would argue with that and you look at a
division that's arguably the worst
division in the league so you've got a
lot of factors set up for for whoever
steps in a quarterback to be successful
now to his credit after some ups and
downs I thought he played his best
football wouldn't mattered at the end of
the season but in terms of you know
whether I'm gonna make any long-term
predictions based off of those those few
games I don't know that I'm ready to do
that just yet okay which is why I love
the contract you know I mean they're
they're able to win yeah too much there
it makes sense for both sides I think
okay Daniel Jeremiah a couple more
minutes left so now that we're heading
to Indianapolis
who else outside the quarterbacks do you
think is gonna show up shout out that
we're gonna see on the NFL Network over
this weekend give me some names well I
think we're gonna be talking about the
overall depth of the running backs and I
think we're gonna be having that debate
a fascinating debate between how high do
you take a back I mean that's going to
be a fun
discussion because you can have people
on one side of the argument pointing to
Ezekiel Elliott and pointing to Leonard
fournette Gurley camara and saying that
works yeah and then you're gonna have
the other people come in and say chimera
in Jordan Howard and and on and on and
on and on so cream hunt so we've got
people entrenched on both sides of that
argument but there are so many good
backs it's gonna be fun to watch all
those guys get out there run around and
and show off a little bit a group you
know I know and Berkeley and Quentin
Nelson for so many people I know it's
not a running back guard League but
those are the two guys that that that
I'm hearing are tops period when you
just want to put guys from one to what
500 those are the top two do you think
there's any chance that maybe the Giants
or the Colts I mean the Colts have got
to protect Andrew Luck I know
everybody's pretty much putting Bradley
Chubb in a Colts uniform right now I'm
gonna chance on any of about that hero I
think I think it's I think it's
definitely possible I I go back to these
philosophy when I was in Baltimore and
he just you know so instead of getting
carried away with home runs in the first
round let's make sure we don't strike
out but let's let's get solid doubles we
know the floor of these players as
opposed to the ceiling and a lot of
times those guys with high floors end up
having high ceilings as well but you get
set back as a franchise you can look at
the Browns when you know you say this
position that position look just get a
good football player get a guys can
start for you for the next eight to ten
years you're not going to have to worry
about it I'm not gonna have to replace
them there's something to be said for
that the good teams they don't miss now
every now and then hopefully you stumble
into a home run but just to avoid the
strikeouts and I think when you look at
guy like Quintin Nelson I mean at worst
he's a great double he might end up
being a 10-year all-pro DJ Daniel look
forward seen in Indy okay have a good
time written for you let's go you got it
and great job with Mike Vick on that pod
oh thanks buddy he was great you got it
yeah I move the sticks podcast with
Bucky Brooks the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience